robbing is blind and relies on guide dog
Hugo to get around but for him and
thousands of others with the disability
voice-activated assistance have opened
up the digital world
Alexa give me the news Amazon is
defending its partnership with the NHS
saying it takes customer privacy
seriously now the NHS wants to use them
to offer reliable health advice starting
with a deal with Amazon to use their
echo devices if you're disabled you know
if your bed-bound for example then you
might not even have access to a phone
but now you can also get this really
invaluable information and you can trust
the source of it to give you you know
really useful correct information that
might actually save lives in our brief
trial it worked
more often than not Alexa what do I do
about a nose bleed to stop a nosebleed
yourself you should sit or stand upright
though not every answer referred to the
NHS using a lexer is the same as looking
for advice on your phone or a web
browser but NHS advice will be
prioritized
but privacy campaigners have significant
concerns about Amazon which last month
admitted that it records and sometimes
listens to conversations you're gonna be
collecting this data about all health
and we don't know how long this is going
to be stored we don't know exactly
hardest is going to be stored and
managed who was in Amazon will have
access to this data so obviously when
we're talking about our health and
almost you know personal and intimate
data I think you know this is something
we should treat with utmost care Alexa
turn off the lights
okay the NHS hopes the partnership is
the first of many with technology
providers that will help relieve
pressure on hospitals and GPS it has
good potential but there are some
concerns about rushing into something
until we know that it's safe and we are
concerned that there are those who don't
have access to this technology who may
be disadvantaged if we rush into it too
quickly
smart speakers are here to stay so
perhaps the real privacy question for
patience may be are you really happy to
share a condition with a lexer that
you'd only discuss with your doctor or
perhaps your best friend Paul Kelso Sky
News